today's episode is presented by t-mobile
America's best unlimited network guys
are you ready for non-us trailer
[Applause]
commentary get to central San Diego Joe
Spencer how crazy is this is nuts man
should we watch it on his trailer with
the people behind the movie one of
y'all's trailers we did all right I
guess we could
how about Deadpool take one for us and
I'm so happy to announce that we have
the director of Deadpool mr. temple
Oh
[Applause]
also from Deadpool he played Colossus
step back the bonds also chimes he's the
creator of Deadpool exports of so many
amazing things mr. rod life oh wow this
is so cool all right guys thank you for
coming guys thank you for having us
probably watch me on a trailer with a
huge room and we're going to sit here a
little worried yeah awkwardly well we
were uh nice on this one you were you
were totally nice yeah my kid guys are
okay me is it dad
honest riddles to get bull and they
liked it and we don't like anything you
don't well before we watch I'm curious
how do you have you guys heard of it and
because we sort of made this joke that
we you ripped off ours in the intro of a
oniton bro you didn't great minds think
alike but they never come across it was
there any sort of honest thoughts before
the movie started you know this is a
leading question cuz he knows the answer
to this [ __ ] question right okay
are there if first of all if there's
kids in here I apologize in advance
because I 21 and over
oh is it oh [ __ ] yeah
Brian was here that would be meaningful
[Music]
yeah so we had decide we had two idea we
had two honest trailer ideas well as one
was I said to Fox why don't we send the
script to the honest trailer guys before
we make the movie so they could tell us
everything that's wrong before and then
they would be complicit in like anything
that was [ __ ] up they would say they
would have to like own it on some level
and then they would see how really cruel
and vicious they are with their little
trailer and then secondly when we did
the we were doing the credits at the end
we had one pitch that was we were going
to do our own honest trailers version of
our movie credits which was pretty
awesome we were going to recap and pick
out all the stupid [ __ ] we had done and
mistakes and just like honest trailers
does leave that to the experts
yeah well we I want to get let's just
want all of you I'd love you to chime in
we have some leading questions we'll ask
as we do this but I think we should
start the trailer let's roll it let's
roll the trailer we'll pause and start
as we go and after but if you would like
to pause at a point to stay on let's see
let's see what it was like pausing back
during studio responsible for this comes
the film they might finally let us
forgive them for this
we pause pump from dude what the [ __ ]
dude I was with my family in the theater
and I'm like well I had heard rumors how
bad this was but I'm like I'm so hoping
for the best I'm over the best right I
know Jim Lee wouldn't saw the night it
open because he was going to gambit oh
and I got to see dead bull uh-uh
like you're like wow you wildly missed
on both horribly Cyclops eyes like what
like oh that's how you get his black
eyes it burns into it oh it's so bad and
I left a note for the Fox execs six
weeks before this a guy named Alex young
and I said dear Alex I've heard horror
stories about this it's not too late
tomorrow to go to a soundstage and have
a guy in shadows come out with a sword
make a nice Deadpool mask and say I'll
be back there something about to make up
for what I hear is awful and I think
they're like Rob it's gonna be fine yeah
was that fine no I don't say that
you know it's closest they don't I
cannot recognize Scott Summers he'll he
changed it looks like Brian Raymond guy
in knockoff Scott Summers yeah it hurt
as bad as you thought it did yeah I mean
Ryan must have there must have been
conversations of this has totally got to
be the opposite Ryan was so scarred by
this experience I mean this end Green
Lantern it was just the whole yeah I
know I know it it wasn't even his fault
hungry but that was getting green either
yeah but now he had he it was vexed
therapy for him doing Deadpool because
he only did this role and he knew was
[ __ ] up the whole time only because he
wanted to get a chance to do it right
the next time
so alright we knew look he's going let's
see what else we did
Deadpool captain Deadpool suit up for
the r-rated film that you had to be 17
to see but 16 to fully appreciate
hashtag I'm in Fox's hugely successful
comic book movie that never would have
been made if someone behind the scenes
didn't fearlessly leaked the test
footage and even then I never would have
been made Paula what do you do like this
I take later if it's someone who runs
with some inch Miller or my mind smells
right I wish I had the gun out didn't it
yeah Rob like did you happen to see like
rah I showed Rob like months before and
I see like a month after Rob comes by
the studio and the teaser like two and a
half minutes long and I see Rob
describing at some panel that I was find
out if there's what this nine minute
test with like action and people dying
and destruction and I'm like what the
[ __ ] is she talking about
he's crazy it was like two and a half
minutes but anyway I did not leave the
trailer Ryan did not leave the trailer
nobody did I'm going to do someone did
alright someone left they somehow like
what I like that there was a high-res
version immediately oh that that was our
fault that that came from Oh help no so
what happened was somebody filmed it and
leaked it and then as soon as it leaked
that the Fox security people call me and
they say hey this is this leaked and I
said I don't know anything do with it
they said he's coming from your server
at blur and I and and then it was it was
a leak that we had sent to agents of
like Ryan's agent WME people like that
and as soon as it leaked somebody just
sent out the link the secure link to a
high-res version on our server because
that was that was not here's what I have
never disclosed it's something you're
aware of but this wool the Wolverine
Origins do you guys remember that leaked
a month early and they went knock on
that lady's door and arrested her like
and and so I was at Fox like you know
2011 20s I you will never know who
leaked this trailer and
and accept their and exact their who I
will not name but he's great guy he said
Oh Rob
we've got cracked like we have the best
technology we can pinpoint exactly the
leak and I was like when this leak I'm
like oh I just hope they don't go to
Tim's door and arrest him like he's got
to make the movie right didn't leak it
Rob left handed allegedly and you know
because because he wasn't arrested we
know he didn't like it yeah alright cuz
they would have known is what you're
saying hey Darren so it's clear very
proud of the fact that they arrested
that lady in her apartment you know in
the Deadpool's
the descript lead to I'd read the script
for Deadpool before I was on the movie
now everybody must know that happened
yeah Ryan Reynolds Captain Jack Sparrow
that's what one of the websites said
back when that was a compliment here
that was a compliment that was a
compliment in 2010 that was a compliment
oh yeah let's keep going we I want to
try and if they intend demanded Bucks
grow up here and release the entire
movie watch is this accidental hit
outgrow story area the amazing so I know
you're mine or into the galaxy every
x-men movie every remember man holy crap
Deadpool no it's for the nation era
Janet Jackson yeah a [ __ ]
Deadpool Wow you're showing up in your
own honest trailer that is so meta let's
do this
meet Wayne Wilson at Ryan's voice oh she
do this on set the whole time I kept
every very proud of as hookers escort
with a heart of gold when cancer sends
wade into Weapon X is non-union
equivalent he'll turn into Deadpool a
wisecracking indestructible psychopath
come on yes love thank you for that hit
a great head enough go-bag except to
talk to her which would have been way
too easy
causing the movie to end in like 20
minutes instead follow along on right
that's a plot hole right he could have
just been like hey I had this thing with
my face he still loved me
no he would still have to go get Ajax oh
[ __ ] you
it would not deserve that I walked her
not one but I was aware I'm it look I
you know everybody reads the the eye you
read what people are talking about and
everybody said yeah the villain plot was
really weak and I totally agree I tell
you can you can't go yeah well you don't
understand what it was no it's weak the
villain plots weak he's gotta be [ __ ]
Jack's fans out like oh no I wait wait
I'm not saying me reaction was weak Edie
was he was a [ __ ] stud he was great
yeah yeah man I disagree I think it's
just a simple story and that's why it
works it's a simple grudge match the
whole movie to give the grody between
simple in simple Rob I think I didn't
direct it this is this is this is simple
and it was I take full responsibility at
least it's not a sky beam like a big
blue hairs just swirling garbage on a
northern guy yeah okay keep playing as
it's a mortal Tucker max battles
villains that pose no real threat to him
full of my signature both wall breaking
I think Brian Reynolds got this far as
superior acting billing quotient of how
many Ryan Reynolds jokes you could do ya
know
Sinead O'Connor internet whatever felt
right jokes then you get a lot quote up
or dick jokes
I already did too many dick jokes you
know now can you do too many dick joke
or episode of Family Guy yes Jimmy kill
why you take the comparison the family
guy's a compliment or not I do
okay good moment for season so for a
story that much like its hero wants to
have it both ways
don't swear they will beautifully make
fun of all the superhero genre is
cliches while giving you the same old
conventional love story and
by-the-numbers revenge but we've seen a
million times before whoa whoa simmer
down there big boy by the numbers
Deadpool is the highest-grossing r-rated
movie of all time yeah
everyone is suck you might know you sure
should be - you back-ass twaddle and
what the [ __ ] is with these beeps you
know kids watch these videos mr. pool
kids King love it when I curse back
turbo boner man it felt good
look the only reason I'm eating fires oh
my god watch out on blu-ray and DVD
bloody ad-libs for a Ryan like how
because we had to write we wrote that
for Ryan and tried to write it in the
voice which we were so honored he
accepted and thought it was in the tone
but like ad-libbing with that onset was
there was there a lot of it like was it
all scripted I would say that we shot
the script first always but then Rhett
and Paul the writers were there every
day and they and Ryan would go through
and they'd write alts and we do him and
sometimes you know you get the
occasional thing that you'd sneak in
like but would he be like soggy dick
Leno let's do better
whale come gargling [ __ ] [ __ ] yeah but
yeah but you know what Ryan's got like a
an encyclopedic memory of like Eskimos
have a thousand words for snow Ryan has
2004 come so like everything you know
he's got that [ __ ] ready to fly and the
role he was born to play it really is
cuz he looks like a nice guy but he is
nasty so so [ __ ] Martin is the best
right the best guys are not nice not not
nice now you do enough blah blah blah
blah like anyone still buys those
glorified in great coasters so let's be
real honest trailer guy I'm Way too big
of a deal to be slumming it in some
played out webseries yeah commenters do
say we're not as funny as we used to be
now comedians in cars getting coffee
tries a show are your Jackman hey hey
hey can I listen to you do the honest
names I love to have problems got a
shortfall anymore sorry what's your
talkative winter talk I'm trying to get
you Jack wouldn't actually just pop by
come on be honest I rent honest trailer
commentaries I'm trying to think
I don't think chef wouldn't like a
schedule or just like because you know
what they got to pay them a [ __ ] ton of
money if they just if they show up and
it's whether it's ten seconds or half
the movie it's like what the heck says
mansion scene like was that on whether
we were going to do a Professor X thing
if we could have decided who you know
which which the different yeah it was
Professor blue swimming Jack we had a
whole Professor X scene written and then
I was like [ __ ] it let's just do
Colossus eating cereal because because
it's cheaper breakfast is the most
important meal of the day
[Music]
he was a great Colossus I loved it you
did a fantastic job
thank you so much let's write we'll
finish out and well that's a couple
questions go ahead the bit you do at the
end of your videos that we quote
borrowed for our opening credits well at
least you're admitting it let me show
you how it's done great just make it
snappy I have to crank out some Deadpool
reacts videos now those brothers aren't
suing people anymore how's it Ari
the Deep Web Rihanna's trans he was
making machines yeah go strong off so
teaching them all a pod go back to ya
cough stronger yes I just want to know
origin of Jakob stronger whose idea was
that and how you yeah we had pitched
about 10 other one the strand we didn't
like any of them and we were exhausted
and I think Andy said oh yeah I got
strong off and that that's the origin
yeah we really maybe yeah yeah cool
stroganoff or something like that you
know I like I'm gonna go hot well thank
you I'm sorry I don't know so said you
didn't like you're starring name that
make me bad how about a colossal II good
guy
[Applause]
so true he is colossus elk elliot they
do be so nice right
all right much bigger than my dentures
keep playing a TJ miller tight amazed
muted negasonic stanley in between
movies sister photo can I do this one
sure it's all yours and as the fetid
testicle wrestler fan even Wilder
alright that way good Ferris Bueller
jerks off Oh what you did there good one
Wow alright I thank you uh and you guys
should have heard the other alts we had
for Stanley I mean I had me well I
haven't I've never been to a strip club
never that but you know you know they
introduced the girls and sometimes what
they say is not very nice and man he had
some foul [ __ ] coming I said I had
Stanley's mouth oh yeah it was legend
right usual everyone right usually heard
him complain that they didn't shoot that
in an actual strip club or we did we're
naked women around at the time there
were totally No yeah was part of the
contra he gets it he was like he was
right on it man yeah it was imagine that
we had this extra who was sitting in
front of this woman they were totally
knew the whole time sitting here the
whole time
and for about the first 10 minutes I'm
like he's the luckiest guy in the world
but after take 20 in an hour and a half
sitting there it's like what do you talk
to what do you talk about with the
stripper where his head is she sitting
Ledford Wasaga yeah yeah exactly it's
Rob you had to be so happy with how the
movie turned out right listen
um III I have a question the original
script like the 2010 didn't it have all
that moody teen and was that not in
there I thought it was getting out of
that none of that was in there that was
and that was an accident that that
opening trailer thing in fact the guys
opening yeah well we did we did an
animatic for the for the title sequence
before we cast the film so
animatics guy Frank Paulson who's here
tonight where is it where is he Frank
where are you there Frank Frank Oh Frank
Frank Frank put a bunch of temp titles
in there moody teen the hot chick all
that stuff and then we just thought it
was [ __ ] funny so we can't really
make it worth it but the whole sequence
going through the van now that was in
that that was in there but it was the
real it was a real titles ok yeah ok
then we had to get all those [ __ ]
lawyer [ __ ] to not have real titles and
Judah Ryan with the ring the green ring
is laugh-out-loud funny every time I
mean I've seen hundred times but you
know it's coming out so awesome but it
has to look like Green Lantern but not
that's right that's right oh I know
those tricks um here's the deal from the
minute I read the screenplay
Rhett and Paul's early draft III it was
such a fresh flavor it wasn't like
anything else anyone else is making and
I mean honestly along the way there was
other guys that came in and out as
directors and I would you sit there
going no say no say no say no and glad
enough guys should know that Jim said
yes and uh and and I was the most
desperate director yeah and that Noah
and I remember I met I met Ken Jim early
on like 2011
and he is right you very kind to me
after he made the animatic I would
routinely every six weeks hey Tim can I
come down I mean it was it got to the
point where yeah I sit here I've been
the theatre Asiya
just play it will talk to you actually
Rob introduced me to Gina
he brought Gina down to the studio not
for this role but for just bird watching
put in his other shitty comic books and
and and she wasn't right for that and
then in it but I but I really I thought
was really liked her and so when you
sweetheart yeah great that's a great
fight Colossus is so I remember after
the test screening Tim was kind enough
to invite me to one of the test
screenings and that's when kind of you
knew this thing they had a hit on their
hands and and I remember going wow the
edited footage everything worked so well
but we stood outside and I remember Tim
said what do you think and I literally
talked about Colossus for like ten
minutes because I'm like the fans have
never gotten a Colossus like this Kim
you have no idea did you know Stefan yes
I prefer them not to hit the woman
did you know could you tell there was a
real something special happening on set
Julie yes well I came later dough but
you know I saw the things yeah yeah yeah
we did we we tried a couple of voice
different voices for classes and none of
them had any kind of you didn't get to
do this voice there I wish I wish you
saw and you knew immediately like oh my
god this is the button you get you do it
on Deadpool to show it'll be easy
they're putting you on sexy to the boys
I don't get to do it on Deadpool to
Bernie did he get to do that Deadpool
dude you are on the set doing it there
now this time well I'm that well I do
you know I would say so many things but
unfortunately I can't right now K those
foxy ninjas they'll get you yeah they
well they tell you they can't be too
honest right see there's things I start
to twin and Tim thinks I'm a bad twitter
or begin with but I'll go recant and
Jeffrey can't recant recant like I just
there's so many that I delete I'm like
this will get me in trouble I have to
edit all the time all the time
well I would have manigott I just want
to say not enough Rob not in not in okay
thanks Evans want to ask you one thing I
have one objection
yeah where is Rob's cameo in your
trailer yeah we should have okay
I'm dealing there and I was so happy to
be there my name is all over the movie
Kim was very kind it's in the barge he
took me up I am eternally grateful and
come on man did you be is fantastic Wow
it is you all I know you're saying
you're not you're not doing Deadpool too
but I know you have some exciting stuff
brewing yes you're doing some amazing
things next one we just all be very
related now I'm not retiring yeah I mean
bummer I would love to see you come to
you but I'm so excited to see you next
because this was your first big movie
and what me Bravo like my only movie
yeah what a knockout out of the park and
you're a few thing I'm sure they came
after you with every movie in the world
right I got a few offers yeah I make a
hit like that just last night I did any
can't say but I did this exact it's
right it's grant me the 20 movies you
turn down it's an awesome list it's
awesome yeah I'm not going to tweet it
but I can't what I was going to get pull
to till almost December November
end of November something like that so
it wasn't like I was jerking offered
yeah no no I was developing that and
then should happen should happen [ __ ]
happens
yeah well I'm excited man I just want to
say to the fans again always there's
always these rumors about I wanted to do
a big movie with the big budget and all
that I don't know where this [ __ ] gets
started from or Kyle Channel I never met
Kyle Chandler any of that any of that
[ __ ] I had somebody for cable that would
have been great but it was not Kyle
Chandler but who although I love Kyle
Chandler cuz he's a coach right yeah
early audition yeah he's good actually
we had it we had another character in
there for a while called Black Swan and
and in Alan Portman look who knew all
right he's an actual he's a German I was
a mercenary yeah he's gentlemen but I'm
excited anyway yeah yeah I wasn't gonna
do some shitty big movie I just want the
fans to know I wouldn't have betrayed
their trust
yes all right I didn't know [ __ ] just
happened believe it I did not get yeah I
wouldn't go thank you forgetful Timmy
Yeah right I mean how great he made it
he did it I mean you must have yes you
can pay nice honest trailer for a reason
that's it yeah it would have been just
like this just with better craft
services well thank you guys so much for
the movie and all your amazing work and
Rob to the caretaker the lights amazing
round of applause for these three and
these guys here this was so much fun
thank you for doing this
that's it thanks so much time this
episode was presented by t-mobile
America's best unlimited network
you